le bestiaire du jardin c'est ainsi que
se nomme cette exposition éphémère
l'insecte en tout genre nous est remisé
sur la nature elle s'est associée à des
établissements scolaires pour mettre en
place ce projet l'objectif que les 200
élèves découvrent le jardin les petites
bêtes qui y vivent
nous avons pu voir la partie
scientifique ils ont pu développer
justement des connaissances autour des
insectes
nous avons eu la chance d'avoir un
entomologiste qui est venu dans la
classe qui leur a montré est différent
différents supports pédagogiques ils ont
pu voir des films aussi avec moi les
enfants dans suite rencontré l'artiste
et l'entomologiste du muséum d'histoire
naturelle ils ont également visité
l'insectarium pour mieux comprendre la
vie des insectes
étape suivante a consisté en la
réalisation de nouvelles créatures nées
de l'imaginaire des enfants avec des
matériaux recyclés le sujet de départ ce
sont des insectes mais moi j'arrive
toujours dans une classe en laissant une
marge de manoeuvre c'est à dire je
travaille avec son désir d enfant donc
on a fait des projets différents avec
laurent on a travaillé sur des masques
avec clarisse on a travaillé sur des
drapeaux etc
j'essaie toujours de trouver une ligne
comme ça qui se croisent entre ce que
j'ai amené à l'apprentissage des formes
des couleurs
de la corruption par exemple de du feu
d'aiguiser la curiosité d'observer et
puis après on aboutit à un projet final
qui passe par des différentes étapes des
croquis de la réflexion ces terroristes
je suis très heureuse d'avoir travaillé
c'est l'enfant qui était vraiment très
investis c'est sur le parvis du muséum
que toutes ces oeuvres ont été exposées
des insectes rigolo qui ont pris de
multiples formes des fabrications mais
également des dessins comment regarder
la nature autrement à travers les yeux
d'enfant désagréable de voir le rendu
des élèves qui arrivent à des courriers
récupérer
des objets recyclables je vois qui a
beaucoup de ressources à exactement
c'était avec des matériaux de recyclage
et donc ils ont leur ils ont eu la
vision sur des revenus qui ne m'avaient
pas j'étais agréablement surpris et pas
forcément je précise bien les meilleurs
de la classe pour moi c'est par la tête
j'ai pris à boulette de papier je les
écraser et j'ai décollé avec deux je les
ai connus
ensuite j'ai fait les yeux je crée des
bouchons en plastique jolivet sur les
pâtes aluminium il est plus solide les
antennes j'ai pris des bâtons glace
gelée aux couleurs de rennes il ya
toujours des conditions actuelles je
viens pas dit sur ce projet s'inscrit
dans le parcours d'éducation artistique
et culturel avec pour objectif découvrir
les arts visuels et les sciences
une occasion également de chanter des
comptines qui parle d infecté
mais non